[Applause]
we need to have a serious discussion on
whether
corona is real or not because you're all
on this [ __ ] you've been waiting for
corona to not be real you've been
hopping in and out of this lake
i really haven't really this way five
years all the crota [ __ ] will be done
and on that day andrew's gonna go i told
you i told you this whole thing was fake
no it was like both sides of the seesaw
no you know how like
they always look back at someone's
tweets like right now they're doing with
lebron they're like in 2019 he said he
was going to bring a championship to la
and it's like
well yeah that's what everybody else
said that was like a year ago yeah but
like
also on every team you're like nah we're
winning it this year yeah but he's not
like prophetic this is what every person
thinks when they go into the season
nobody's like nah we coming in third
like why would you go into basketball if
that was the case so
i just take both sides so i can just
cherry-pick
there's a video of skip bayless arguing
against skip bayless about aaron rodgers
they're gonna have one of those with you
and corona i love i love it and let me
give them
everything they need you ready yeah you
don't think this [ __ ] is real
i'm i really don't know if it's real
dude i know it's real cause 200
000 people died i'm not trying to say
that you know they faked their deaths
obviously
yeah put you out there now what make
that joke
that's not a question in 10 years time
there's going to be covid deniers it's
going to be [ __ ] [ __ ]
do you believe in cloven yes do you yes
a documentary is going to come out and
it's going to have some conspiracy
theories i hated that
everybody i know you don't believe in
kovit you know how i know because you
started dressing like you're from new
york again
what's happening look how alex dressed
today i could tell martin lost
confidence in your point he was so ready
to co-sign and he was like
did i go through puberty in my
i was about to be on to something yeah
mark lost confidence no i still
obviously he was ready and then
y'all made me lose confidence no i'm
still with it i'm still with it yeah
your outfit sucks no i think it's good i
know it is really good
what mark shut up i hate you mark you're
fake too you're the worst hype man ever
yeah where's my blink when you need him
i know which way he's going ever
you know
no look what i'm trying to say is i
don't think that
corona is completely fake right go ahead
okay this is the nuance first there's
some corona
let me be objective there's some corona
out there that's undeniable okay okay
get to the denial part please how we've
handled it okay
how we've handled it okay very poor yes
and what i mean by that is
we shouldn't have closed anything down
um okay i'm watching wheezy's instagram
story i'm watching mandy's instagram
story shout out to horrible decisions
they're out there in mexico for lack of
a better word
whoring it the [ __ ] up okay
okay i believe that's an appropriate
word based on their podcast and how they
identify themselves
yeah okay al am i right on that yeah
well these [ __ ] buckets are out there
dancing
already
yo you know if you bail i'm going harder
i know buddy
was that really that crazy yeah come on
dude come funnels yeah come on
we would never speak disrespectfully to
women around you
okay yes keep that in mind never ever
ever once will we do that that's true
right now that was not disrespectful we
were talking about lubed up esophagus
for real for real okay all i want to say
is
they are partying like crazy it is
unbelievable what's going on there
can i sent me a video that she told me
that she's not gonna post but i'll talk
about it
it's just a party yeah it's a party
everybody is going to mexico to party
okay we know this for a fact
everybody's going to mexico from around
the whole world because mexico never
shut down their borders yeah right
uh we know that about y'all
okay we've been trying to shut that
[ __ ] [ __ ] down for a while
okay they don't believe in shutting down
borders not even during kovac
people are flying there from around the
world you went
do you have kovit no so riddle me this
riddle me this okay science
nerd dork
[Laughter]
you're back on board okay so riddle me
this if the whole world
is going to mexico partying together
no social distancing okay
smooching it up i saw full-on makeouts
bikinis
people coughing breathing dancing
methamphetamines
all over the place yes methamphetamines
dude i saw
meth amphetamines both of them both of
them not just one that they had
both of them meth amphetamine
there was random stimpy and
methamphetamine i saw them all down
there in mexico
yeah okay yeah keep going
they should be getting corona passing it
around if it's as contagious everybody
says
and then bring it back to their
respective cities around the world why
is this not happening
um what is this how do you know it's not
happening
now you can only get corona in
republican gatherings exactly
why is it right you can't get corona
black lives matter martial
the lakers parade that's the taylor's
parties in mexico
that's valid that's valid why is it
melanin kill coronas no because white
people are afraid to try to uh say black
people are doing anything wrong because
they're [ __ ]
i think that's racist i think corona is
racist yeah who's [ __ ]
who's [ __ ] the woke white people were
shaming the republicans for going to the
gatherings but won't be like
hey guys can we not go to mexico to
party it up
they want to find a way to make this not
fun
did you find a way to make something
really fun not
fun by analyzing it i thought you were
being we did it to bill burns
sharks in hell for the first 20 minutes
of this [ __ ] podcast
i thought you were being serious that's
my bad i'll take that because
you just had a party party had a
birthday bash
okay [ __ ] and spin decks
there should be corona all over the
place but it's not there why not
melanin melanin i've been said black
people can't get it
that's actually a good point she said
that a long time you know i said that a
long time ago and people got upset at me
for that
they said i was the reason that corona
was allegedly ravaging the black
community
because black people are trusting me and
they're going out there and breathing
all over each other that's very cheap
you know the only black person that got
it herman cain
republicans republicans hanging out
targeting
republicans you want to know why you
want if we're going to get really
conspiracy theory you want to go real
conspiracy theory yeah
you know why because it's a it's a bug
controlled by china
and you know who they want in office yep
they don't want donny t in office
they want joe biden in office they want
them blue coats
mm-hmm they want them blue coats why do
they want the blue coats
because they like china more
okay all right all right okay
why else yeah i'm waiting i thought you
knew the answer and i was going with you
on that one
are we passing around the hot potato the
hot potato's been passed
akash you better be ready yes okay you
better be ready it's going to mark and
what's the question again mark you
should have been paying attention
archives language
because the blue coats are [ __ ]
decent found a way to do it again
you found a way to do it again bring
back the chris rock
it's a momentum
no can he say the n word i could say the
[Applause]
okay yo taylor that's like when he did
those braids
they were cornrows but they looked like
it and you know what he was trying to do
devil horns they were what white devil
okay just making sure
just making sure which group you were
putting horns on mark
just making sure so many times i'm
looking at that i'm like
and then i was like okay i'll be feeling
like
wait hold up and then
[Applause]
you looking at him sideways because i i
missed him he said the n word no he
didn't say the n word he literally saw
it though the n word but even that i
don't know if i want him to say
wait what about the n-word you're gonna
speak into your mind what about the
n-word i thought he was gonna say it in
a chris rock impression i thought that
would be offensive
so i was making sure he didn't say it so
i said don't say the n-word i kind of
like
consider anyone that's my
skin complexion in like like
he's allowed to say the n word i want to
i don't think i would be here
i don't be saying it but i'm good though
i could
no you know what she makes an
interesting point and i i have an
argument as to why he should be allowed
do you know one race interested do you
know
oh gosh is bad you know do you know an
interesting you know a racial term used
against akash
do you sand n-word
so people call him the n-word too
um yeah i mean but i just look at like
people that have my no like
how lazy is that how lazy are racists
that they're like i don't know just
throw edward at the end of it
where does he live in the sand at the
end of that [ __ ]
that's great you start calling hawaiians
like island n words
canadians ice and words yeah yeah that'd
be crazy have you heard the pc
i've been called the dune [ __ ] oh dudes
the pc version of it it's even lazier
it's like yeah i can't say the n word
just ah
dude there you go yo but what racist is
like you can't say the n word
white so white racist won't say the n
word but they're still racist
wait hold on wait what it's like the
pg-13 racial slur yeah i mean i'm just
saying if you try this at school and get
away with it
i know i know but i'm saying is if
you're racist towards somebody clearly
you're not going to be
you know um apologetic about using the
animal right you would just go for it
but we
found a subset of racists who even
acknowledged that the n word that's true
it's too racist for their racism that's
true that's how racist the n word is
i could say that [ __ ] though did you
ever give your theory why corona is
actually over
it's it's not over i think that we're
handling it the wrong way
sweden okay okay i saw
in the beginning i wish we handled it
like sweden like sweden sweden
never even did the mass you go to a mall
in sweden they don't got no massive just
walking around normal some people died
don't get me wrong
they died but apparently they're back to
the same levels as everybody else in
europe but their economy didn't take no
hit
and in terms of death levels their
economy didn't take a hit at all
and uh say that again they have higher
herd
immunity save higher herd immunity so
that more i guess more people can't um
pass it on yeah right so and that's the
thing that's like you
they they point to certain places like
new zealand which like blocked it out
really well
like they just had this big i think it
was rugby match that mark was showing me
with like
tons of people in the stands like tens
of thousands of people in the stands
just watch and rugby
and none of them had mass or anything
like that right
here's the thing there's no herd
immunity there because nobody got that
[ __ ]
so my thing is well if you open up the
country eventually some people are going
to come where they have it and now
you're going to have spread all over the
country it's not like this thing is
going to go away
the only option is hurt immunity so you
need to let [ __ ] get it
they're probably just banking on keeping
it closed until um vaccine is
created that's a good point
you